&gt;&gt; I'm going to momentarily make these problems at the bottom small and just
show you the answers to the first three. Then we'll move onto the last two
later. So here's the work and the answers for the first three problems. We have
x is less than negative 3, x is greater than or equal to negative 2, and x is
greater than three. Of course with this last one, we started out with x on the
right side of the equation, and some people prefer to put the variable on the
left side in the answer. So if you want to follow that convention, then to get x
onto the left side, you also need to flip the inequality so that it's facing the
opposite direction. Saying that 3 is less than x is also the same as saying, x
is greater than 3. And now moving on to our last two problems. And after several
steps we end up with x is greater than or equal to 4 and x is greater than 4.